welcome to this video mr. Boris yep and
he would get the the Trump I have played
this guy before with a pretty good score
so I hope to continue in that in that
Wayne it Sam they place the Trump and my
aunt I doubt here that I played is there
is one of those super safe continuations
we're like is equalizing pretty easily
but it's not very exciting must must be
honest there well ok it's also also
whites whites problem a little bit with
this openings oh yeah what really if I
have no no tactic here kind of kind of
surprising looks took some what wrong
it's maybe maybe I'm seeing don't see it
clearly default bishop ji-hye if there
is no tactic addy in 19th now
couldn't be six not leading to anything
okay yeah why did I take really why did
I take this is just good for white now
and quite obviously so I don't know kind
of difficult at the moment to play I
play very weird stuff let's see can I am
how do I get some kind of position I
castle long I'm very close to getting
checkmated here with with Boden's made
with Quincy six bishop asics made but
what can you do castling Sean also looks
very dangerous this mating idea with
Queen c6 bishop asics made I really have
to be cautious this is very close to
being on
yeah it will show you I will show you a
simple simple line to illustrate it
maybe I am I somehow allow it in the
game it's not it's easily possible and
the meeting idea that remembers Quincy
6b takes bishop asics made at the moment
my queen is covering the maid square
this is why I so I is thinking probably
because it's a well-known meeting motive
and it kind of smells with that it might
be might be on okay so not not directly
at least let's push this away check
Queen takes Bishop jinx and no Bishop
takes maybe for Bishop c7 trading
trading stuff and night this is very
awkward 96 is very awkward
okay it's not really not really
attractive but I want to ship c7 they
don't want the night to hit so quickly
here they can take now Bishop takes but
Bishop e7 keep things together very very
awkward at least I'm not behind on the
clock that's the only little positive
thing that I can say here
and I probably won't take any way I did
it take so that pre-move would have been
okay yeah interesting take you on c6
doesn't look very ambitious but it's
kind of awkward here to make a move even
really awkward we should be 896 is also
plan and not a not an easy plan actually
to fight I should have thought about
that so I for at least a moment a ok
Knight f6 maybe and then 96 check hits
Wow amazing amazingly bad position
Bishop man Bishop yet is coming I have
to go back and really have two bishops
e6b takes ok oh maybe I can play Bishop
c6 Quincy six
Joe it looks like total rubbish maybe
I'm summer ruling
huh he's taking some time maybe not
finding something decisive which kind of
check yeah it's kind of it looks like
there should be something okay yeah now
he's in a almost kind of self pen but ok
g7 hangs mm-hmm up to eight TX Knight
takes Queen g7 I have no no check or or
whatever Jim and g6 okay maybe maybe
this can still summer hold with with
just it's mostly with mostly one
weakness queen d 3 root d8 is an
interesting question is this what is
this king and porn endgame okay so we
get get a different end game
check written Quigley one mate it's nice
to threaten something ok quindi five is
probably not a good idea don't think
that a king opponent game here can be
any good I shoot them try for some kind
of Perpetual just attacking two pawns
great just great this is also a way to
lose this after I was basically out of
the woods I almost almost check time
warning
check check check check check check
check check looks like a drawer Jack gay
humming branch yep I'd is a draw well
whoo that was a really really bad
position yeah I will be plated brindis
badly in the opening this is this is
totally normal and should be should be
all right so he took two can play before
it kind of looked a bit dubious to me
like in those pieces but there's nothing
this would have been good yeah that
would have been good point it out by the
engine the point is that this is this is
quite okay nice God Bishop b5 though
yeah still I should have done that this
this was a really bad idea I mean this
is leads to this very very unattractive
position where you just suffer for for
no end yeah i played this more i wanted
to show you the maid that i was was
talking about um how how to do that
let's say why does this and i play black
place i need to do something quite
stupid him to allow it um I don't know
I have I have an idea to do that let's
say here here here here and then it is
this is checkmate this is Borden's mate
first played by a person called borden
german word for for floor so we had some
trades instead and I'm suffering
suffering suffering ok here the comp
points out before with the win p for 26
roop t1 yeah we have a that's very
awkward by Queen has no squares and so
on so it stays very awkward ok now this
this is basically basically admitting
then that the worst is over I'm still
suffering here bit but I I shouldn't use
anymore and here this is this is just
just a stupid move and probably do
something like that just make sure that
I have those two pawns to defend and
then not more King will go here and then
I can basic just basically just stay
white can pretend to have something with
this better structure but it's um it's
the danger of some kind of perpetual is
just too high okay thanks for watching